today's topic you know who sniper SSS
Sniper Wolf is no one of the biggest
YouTubers on the platform oh yeah I
think I heard that his name once or
twice her it's a she so she does
reaction videos very popular but people
accuse her of stealing the way she does
it they don't feel like it's ethical
feeling the the way she does this kind
of like she's oh wow that's kind of
crazy and then she goes to the next
video so it's not really much
interaction with the content itself oh
she does basically what she does is the
bare minimum not to get yeah copyright
straight and uh fair use I mean could we
even say it's a bare minimum but most
people can't according to the law does
it pass I think if people try to suit
her they would win I don't know this
person and I haven't seen the content so
I can know but I'm just asking for my
knowledge is she doing the bare minimum
for it to pass as fair use most people
would say no okay okay but again one of
the most successful YouTubers in fact
YouTube kind like they highlight her at
events they show her a lot of love okay
but she was getting called out by this D
dude for quite some time who kept making
videos on her content basically saying
yo what she did is wrong I think his
name is Jax films and ain't nothing
wrong with that you know he's basically
Yoshi's a thief and he was doing a bunch
of stuff and you know it got some
traction so I'm not going to PO the
story cuz you know private information
she had this guy's address she went to
his address went on Instagram said hey
Jack I'm outside we can talk and like
she you know in front of all her
followers showed the house so everybody
she do she doxed them on top of
that o okay this is like public and her
huge follow you talking about 30 mil
Subs okay popular in front of the
persons and post that house and stuff no
that's foul that's wild so that's foul
she does all
that he finds out he loses it he's
calling YouTube he says listen I'm home
with my wife this girl knocks my address
you know threatening life YouTube you
know you should take her down this is
against the rules she should be banned
which everybody gets in on it but the
thing that happened is that because
she's profitable I guess YouTube don't
don't really care it's going to take a
whole lot they took action
oh that's the big update so that's
good they temporarily demonetized her
temporarily why stamp after a lot of
backlash and everybody yelling about it
so okay is the amount of money that you
bring
in talk go ahead I don't know I'm I mean
it's
listen obviously I don't have all the
ends of this story but it don't look
good why would you temp hurt we're
talking about doxing if I oh my God I
don't want to do
that I do not want to do that do what
[__] it if a guy was doxing a girl like
that people would be oh safety safety
safety and You' be hella mad and you
would be doing them something m opo you
don't think so no I don't think it has
anything to do with gender you think
it's a gender thing no I don't know I'm
just putting everything out there like I
said before I do not have the
information but and if she's a big big
big big YouTuber if she makes a lot of
money they make a lot of money it goes
hand in hand why T we're talking about
doxing I don't have all the information
but what I know and what I see from what
I from what I gather right now what you
told me it don't really look good at
Tamp band for
docking that's big a ass
that's a safety breach and not only that
your your fair use is not even fair use
so I don't know sounds kind of weird but
I mean she's won the gold in I think
what it really comes down to is just
money and no matter how many YouTubers
get mad about it here's the truth
YouTube doesn't really care because it
doesn't affect their
advertisers you know when Russell BR had
his situation however you feel about his
content the kind of stuff he post or at
the end of the day they were just
allegations right were they credible to
some degree if you read the news article
like there's some but YouTube doesn't
generally act because allegations came
up they wait for a verdict to be done
and then once that done they terminate
the channel but in this case they
demonetized him fully why because there
was so much news coverage about Russell
bran there was literal governments
messaging them that they took action in
those situations and generally the way
that they operate from what I've noticed
and there the patterns I see is YouTube
just doesn't like it when big
Publications come talking yes I didn't
see what you're saying that's all they
care about so YouTubers posting videos
on their platform it don't really matter
if Forbes is not talking about it if all
these other spots not talking about it
they don't care even them taking this
action and temporarily Banning her
monetization right that's only because
YouTubers were going crazy calling them
out endlessly and then finally they did
something but what it really comes down
to is like how much money do she make us
how much of a net benefit she is what's
the risk if we keep her on and if the
risk is low which it is because here's
the thing this is going to blow over
sniper wolves fans are all 13 and under
so they don't give a no they don't they
don't even know what doxing is it just
sound like a foreign website to those
kids okay so at the end of the day as
long as she makes some money that's I
think they know what dxing is I don't
think they really care I don't these
yeah these kids know someone's add
they're posting the whole lives online
you think they care about someone
posting add they don't care they don't
care kids be out here in front of the
out doors I think they know what it is
they don't care what it is I don't even
think most adults know what doxing is
you know because you're in the online
space sure most people don't know
honestly before I did YouTube I didn't
even know what doxing was a thing okay
well the the thing about without saying
the word doxing divulging someone's
information private information is
something that you shouldn't do sure to
to millions and millions of people
regardless of the fact that you don't
know the exact term and word for it
online broadcasting someone's private
information whether it's credit card or
whether the person lives is not
something that you should do sure so
yeah most people know it's bad they
don't know it's doxing when it's online
but they they know it's bad when you
broadcast yo that's where that person
lives yo that person lives there there
there you know you shouldn't do that
yeah and you know why you shouldn't do
that you don't need to be inside the
doxing yeah the word the term I can
understand that us people know what it
is yeah so I think it's is one of those
situations
where nothing's going to happen I I'm
not expecting anything to happen it
would have been shocking har Potter over
if they it would have been shocking if
they would have done anything serious I
would come up here and say you know what
YouTube this is really surprising you
actually took action when you were
supposed to but they don't they don't
care because they don't have to care
they're really concerned about their
money yeah when use Publications taken
on it's just different because then
advertisers get worried yep like oh the
image nobody cared about PewDiePie doing
any of his [__] moment a couple news
Publications started putting articles
about how rist he was all of a sudden
YouTube came down when they banned them
temporarily for some time temp temp but
that's only after that happened that's
always it's not because they missed it
it's not because it wasn't aware it
wasn't reported to them because it
wasn't a big deal I'm telling you man
when you're big enough on this platform
you can get like it's crazy because
we're at 2 million now so you guys would
think we're that big but we're not we're
mid there's like levels like we're still
Expendable you saw freshit got
demonetized easy they're at 1.5 easy
peasy lemon squeezy they can get rid of
us we don't bring in that kind of money
you know when you're talking about
sniper you're talking about tens of
millions hundreds of millions over the
course of a year or two definitely it's
a different level so all this to say big
players play by big rules think about
sports M they have Superstars Superstars
get different rules they get Superstar
calls in basketball they get treatment
preferential treatment right they get to
sit out and they have rules now in the
NBA for people to be able to do what
load management but that's only for
Superstars people who reached a certain
level they have different rules even
ifif what what just for us I go by I I
go I go in the bar people pay me drinks
sure I can afford my drinks it's when I
was poor that you should have my drinks
you know what I mean like I get all
these I'm not not mad at it that's the
that's the game that's the that's the
name of the game all these industries
have that so like the reason why I'm
telling you guys this is just to say
this understand the game so you can
manage your expectations this whole idea
of Justice if you say and speak out
you'll get Justice that's just not going
to happen it won't happen when it comes
to war it won't happen com to business
it won't happen when it comes to life in
general that's just not the way it works
everything is about leverage and the
people who are complaining about Sniper
Wolf have zero leverage the news
Publications can affect ad dollars it's
a different ball game so so you spoke to
the
[__] from Live Nation I was
going to wait for you to be there I
wanted to wait for you so I'm going to
set up a call so we're just going to set
up a call I'm not going to be here for
the call I'm going to be in my home so
we can do okay we can do that too where
am I going to sit on your bed I ain't
sitting on your bed [__] that's not gay
that's gay it's only gay if we both sit
on the bed no that's gay one guy sits on
the bed I'm not sitting on your bed I'm
not don't don't sit it like that I'm not
sitting on don't say it like that you
going sit on my couch yeah is fny it's
not
about you paused no didn't yeah yeah I
said you want to some my catch your face
cuz I know your intention what my
intention yeah you a gay ass [__] hey
I'm not sitting on your bed you sit on
my couch either yeah yeah what why you
ain't got no couch that's part of it you
got rid of it but even if I didn't you
just can I sit on your couch that's C no
you just say can I sit no no no cuz it's
a couch it's me for that that's what I'm
saying so if you if you sit
you B not for sitting all people watch
at home how many of y'all sit in your
bed every now and then no no it's not
why you sit on your bed I sit on my bed
all the time I'm not sit on other
people's beds that's your problem yeah
before I [__] him
that's exactly all right why am I
sweating not gay I was biking a biking
is not gay either n unless you remove
the [__] seat huh huh whoa what
that's crazy you're just suppos some
Next Level Tech is there anything else
you want to say no all right let us know
what you guys think